[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine du département et tout de suite
l'actualité en tire un milliard 629
millions d'euros c'est le budget
primitif de la collectivité pour l'année
il a été voté à l'unanimité en séance
plénière par les élus du département
un budget en hausse de 2,1 pour cent par
rapport à 2010 7 90 millions d'euros
seront attribués au pacte de solidarité
territoriale à destination des 24
communes de livres 90 millions dont 75
millions en investissement et 15
millions en fonctionnement et pour moi
c'est l'expression d'une solidarité très
forte avec les maires pour bois parce
que nous sommes mary et départements les
collectivités qui travaillons dans le
champ de l'action sociale et dans la
proximité proximité avec les familles
réunionnaises surtout celles qui sont
les plus en difficulté proximité avec
les jeunes qui sont en difficulté
d'associations proximité avec nos g de 7
à 16 ans c'est l'âge de nos jeunes
gymnastes qui ont participé dimanche
dernier aux épreuves qualificatives pour
le championnat de france
en qualité on a réussi à créer un sport
études
place aux classes à horaires
par contre ça démontre
beaucoup d'investissements handicap
aux passions et
une jolie complète 23 pour la 23e
édition du concours national du poi sont
magiques un concours de dictée braille
pour les personnes aveugles ou
malvoyantes
une dictée extraite d'un article de ces
news matin les termes étaient assez
simples
après c'est vrai que je pense que ce
qu'il ya enfin le plus compliqué serait
tout ce qui est en situation souligné
voilà les sites aussi internet donc une
façon de mettre les chiffres dans
quelques chiffres romains
je pense que ça c'est ce qui est très
compliqué le chiffre 1 pour la pose de
cette première pierre de la future
piscine et centre nautique des 10 euros
sur la commune de saint philippe
pour les premiers plongeons il faudra
attendre le 1er semestre 2010 9
le département a financé à hauteur de 1
million 30000 euros
cet équipement c'était très important
pour les départements de participer à la
production de cette piscine
comme vous le savez que 4400 philippe
les élèves étaient obligés de descendre
sur saint joseph pour apprendre à nager
et ça a vraiment c'était pas possible de
continuer comme ça fait une façon de du
départ devant être plus proche des
communes afin de concrétiser le projet
depuis le 12 février 2018
le sentier reliant bois court à grand
bassin est fermé l'office national des
forêts a signalé la présence de blocs
rocheux instable sur le site
suite aux fortes intempéries de ces
dernières semaines nous sommes
confrontés à trois et moulis
et une zone de fragilité du sentier
d'assises le tout avec un élément qui
complique un petit peu la gestion du
dossier s'il ya une canalisation la
qualié sur les hirondelles des
canalisations d'eau potable qui est
dessous le 8 mars
c'était la journée internationale de la
femme à cette occasion les femmes
pompiers ont débattu le temps d'une
journée sur leurs conditions au sein des
différentes filières administratives
professionnels ou volontaires
ben je crois que les femmes apportent
leur côté féminin
une vue une approche peut-être un peu
différente de celle des hommes tout en
sachant que nous travaillons dans un
corps de pompiers la majorité de nos
collègues sont des hommes
on aimerait bien que les gens nous
voient pas dedans comme le maillon
faible de certains métiers on est aussi
capable de faire aussi bien que les
hommes
et sinon mieux treize pour cette 13e
édition du prix célimène une visite
virtuelle de l'exposition est disponible
sur le site internet www.cglpl.fr pour
le bonus de cette semaine je vous laisse
découvrir le nouveau spot vidéo du
département il fait la promotion des
équipements culturels de la collectivité
et de l'antenne de paris
[Musique]
dumont
nous
[Musique]